- I thought on Christmas,
it would be a great
opportunity to show you
what I think is one of the greatest
lawyer jokes of all time.
And that's a Merry Christmas
card from your lawyer.
Whoever wrote this is clearly an attorney
or works with attorneys.
It's just absolutely perfect,
to show that you're not guaranteeing
that you wish them a Christmas,
that the expectations
are set with a reasonable
Merry Christmas and/or
festive period, including,
but not limited to a happy
again, reasonable New Year.
And then the best part
of all is of course,
that you have to spell out
12 with a number one and two,
because that's just what lawyers do.
So congratulations to whoever wrote this.
This is one of the greatest
lawyer jokes of all time
and from Legal Eagle,
I wish all of you a Merry
Christmas and/or festive period,
your mileage may vary.
Please consult with your attorney.